all right everybody i have for you a
truly
bizarre clip of marjorie green and matt
gates talking about a weird fantasy of
something or another and i just need to
apologize upfront before we look at this
some percent of you are going to
whenever you watch this you're going to
throw up
um
not really you'll be fine but it is it's
cringy so let's take a look his favorite
member
he's mine i'm on record he's at the top
for me like i would rather give nancy
pelosi a sponge bath than endure like
one dinner
totally but but just to just to bring
this i don't have a color for you okay
like like a lot of people would say
maybe pelosi is their least favorite
member no way
i would trim her toenails with my teeth
before i would go to dinner without him
that's really impressive
so here's how i feel now i know some of
you will watch that and be like it was
weird but why are you making a big deal
first off it's just kind of a fun story
a lot of heavy stuff lately let's laugh
at a couple goofballs but
also there is a larger important point
so first let's just go through how weird
what they were saying was for some
reason to express his hatred for adam
schiff he had to do some big long
fantasy
about
giving nancy pelosi a scrub-down bath
and then biting her toes doe toenails i
i don't know why that was so specific
and
seemed kind of pre-planned
maybe something he's thought about
before but
really weird um
so that's that but then the larger
more meaningful and serious point is
this is a great example of how
right-wing politics has gotten so far
away
from serious discussions about how to
address problems in our country
and i know you know that but watching
clips like that really remind you of it
marjorie green doesn't have any
committee assignments she's not
working on policies each day she has her
one vote in congress but besides that
she's not really doing much and what she
is doing is being a little media figure
and that's what we've seen a lot of
these republican politicians become it's
not about
policy it's not about implementing
policy that will help improve the lives
of your constituents no it's about being
a media figure it's about being an
influencer she has a little mtg live
that's what it's about
and so right there he's being a little
funny guy you know saying some weird
stuff that might get his audience to
laugh
being completely
unserious and not at all trying to
address the many many issues that need
to be addressed in our country and so
while
the core reason i wanted to play that
clip is because it's just absurd
and let's just think one more time one
more time about
matt gates
saying
he would rather give nancy pelosi a
scrub-down bath and
cut her toenails with his teeth
then go out to dinner with adam schiff
i don't think he's inviting you bubba
but okay um
bizarre
but also an indication like i said
that they don't care it's not about it's
not serious this isn't about making
change for their constituents
they're just trying to go viral they're
trying to be provocative
trying to be the biggest name in the
republican party
tweet out stuff own the libs
that's what it's really about it's no
longer
at all policy focused and that's super
super sad
and something we need to continually
call out and we need a demand of the
politicians we like and support that
they stay focused
on the real issues
i appreciate the dave pacman show having
me uh fill in today it's been an
absolute pleasure i'll just plug one
more time go check me out luke beasley
on youtube
we got it papa lochen over there you can
also listen to the show as a podcast
just luke beasley
anywhere you go you should be able to
find me instagram twitter all those good
things luke p beasley on twitter and i
will hopefully see you guys in the near
future